welcome to this video playing Kyle
oshawa that's a that's a new pairing
never happened before okay so getting
one going for that man tamil off but
he's not going to comply playing the
Kings Indian attack hmm okay yeah that
setup is some a pretty universal while
we loop a pretty Universal one that
black and employ against many Kings
Indian attack close Sicilian type of
lines my idea is actually to go for this
I know it looks slow with that double
double movement of the e pawn but that
structure that boat Vinick structure um
it's actually pretty comfortable for
black so I like this even though it
costs a bit of time III is going for
before you can also play a five but I'm
never sure if that's a good idea because
of a four by white but then this is a
completely okay yep came to support that
porn now it's complete development I
have a good grip over the d4 square so
it's not going to play d4 anytime soon
now dear for why this may be really be
five I know it like be five my light
moves and then c4 no he's not doing that
okay maybe he wants to what's this idea
dude does you want to play a four or
something it would be really completely
entire positional playing on the
queenside where I'm clearly stronger
already
b5 is ok but you don't need the rukon be
one for that yeah thats thats it's not
good i think going to let's not pre-move
unnecessarily but yeah this is just good
for black here I've got the better play
in the sand I'm threatening d for
winning a piece and that's that that's
going to be awful Knight to c3 now I can
do this with the tempo or maybe I can do
Knight c3 actually can do that
immediately I'm threatening only towards
check so hmm I want none that it doesn't
matter let's just play 94 you will have
to check with the bishop no okay I'm
guessing absolutely no more item but
that looks disastrous ready whereas this
Bishop going
so now I can win that exchange or or
play m9 f1 which is also rather tempting
huh well gay that's let's grab the
exchange I mean hate is hanging well it
doesn't really matter I have Bishop d5
and if it takes a eight now a detour is
captured with the tempo and that should
be should be excellent or can you then
play Queen g2 as weird as it looks hmm
i also have g5 which would trip that
with trap that Bishop
would have been an interesting with as
well actually mmm okay but beyond g5g
five is a pisa ultimately you should pay
eight digs no then he then you retreats
okay let's just keep the exchange I have
to watch the chime a little bit um some
some side he's got an amazing neck going
on why am i oh I i also have a problem
here yeah i recently i had lagging
problems with the the icc server yeah
yeah yeah i lost like a ton of time here
but no I'm I'm somehow back wow it's
crazy I hope I'm not losing you too
connection is your issues disconnecting
is losing here always okay oh yeah I
guess let's take it
huh I still seems to be a connection
issue we had no that can be that can be
a problem Emily so where is he going
bishop age six is that a threat you
should be age six village six light have
six check might be hmm but I really
should close that door always have that
washing machine sound in the background
it isn't it doesn't feel right okay so
let's see let's step out of that Bishop
e2 six business and green a2 is also
something to keep in mind
um if I just take it oh but it's not
really necessary how you can just try to
win that porn without anything fancy
happening Luke takes you four was also
pretty pretty good
that porn should be really really strong
white resigns yep yeah now that a form
officer I mean already called it before
he played it that this is really
completely a completely anti positional
um okay would be one is already not not
doing much but I think I'm what white
can think of is to just play this move
and then kick my night no no maybe think
about this it's it's a playing against
this 91-85 however I'm quick with F fry
him now I'm very quick with f5 maybe
that isn't the plan either hmm i don't
know i mean i like Blackie anyway that
black centers is simply difficult to
play against you cannot go t4 and i have
clear plants green d7 later f5 I think
like is okay it's really not so clear to
me what what white is doing in this
position long-term yeah this is a day
for it's just bad and its just oh that's
just that's just bad you might 85 is an
additional problem maybe this is what
the engine is suggesting that this is a
somewhat crazy continuation but in fact
that's interesting
as such this too is just a slight
advantage for black according to the
comp compounds to play f6 yeah this is
actually good from wide okay yeah that
means it wasn't so bad I mean the idea
in itself is not particularly yeah I
mean it's a bit of a believer funny
resource at the divorce working what if
I do this take here now you can do this
because Bishop d4 that's route d 1 wow
ok I did this and now it's it's over
really yeah minus one point something no
not a matter of choosing between many
many good moves the biggest danger was
my my weird connection issues yeah okay
well thanks for watching